hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I want to talk about
one of my favorite tools to run my
business and it's called 99designs I
file it here on my blog of my favorite
tools so I'll just go down and find it
here and what you can use 99designs for
its basically anything that's design
related for your business so if you need
a logo a website business card t-shirt
banner ad or whatever it is any kind of
design it's a great place to check out
and one of the main reasons why i like
it is you're not actually paying for the
work until you get a finished product so
most of the time when you're working
with designers you're working with
artists right and and you can look at
their past portfolio see what they've
done but you're not quite sure what
you're going to get for your project so
9am designs you're only paying for a
final product which is fantastic for an
entrepreneur so i'll show you hear what
I've done in the past some of the
projects I've worked on my contest here
so here are three that i've done so i
had a website header a local and
powerpoint the design and an info
graphic artist that I've hired so in the
first one a website header I was looking
for someone to you know make a new
design for me at the top and I had 12
entries and I didn't like any of them
and I didn't end up paying for the
winning design so there was no risk to
me except a little bit of time in kind
of launching that project logo in
PowerPoint design and the info graphic
artist I did end up hiring and so again
you're only pain when you get a final
design that you actually like and are
happy with it and implement into your
business which again is fantastic so
I'll show you an example if I click on
my info graphic artist what I wanted to
do here was get some complex you know
content some articles and turn them into
cartoons via an infographic and wanted
someone to help me do that and I
a winning bid here by the lion king so
what happens here is you know i'll post
my description and I said I had 154
dollars that was my my bid I had 25
people who entered into it and basically
what will happen is you'll see this as
you go through so people will start
submitting designs this is my winning
design and you can see all sorts of
other designs that people submit and
what you can do as you see these designs
is leave feedback so you can give them a
star rating out of 5 and you can also
say you know I really like this design
but I'd love to see it with an orange
top and then they can come back and give
it to you with an orange top so there is
a period of time we can communicate with
the designer to say what you like what
you don't like and then at the end if
you do like one you can pick you know
you're winning designer award them the
money but just before that you can also
run a poll and so you can see here
you're running a poll one person is
voted or create new poll so we can do is
you can take your top five designs and
maybe you're not sure because you've
looked at them so much and you're not
quite sure which when you go with you
can create a poll it'll give you a link
you can send it to your friends or your
customers or partners or staff or
whoever you want to send it to for
feedback and they can vote on it so you
can say here are my top five designs I
want a new infographic I want a new logo
what do you guys think and they can all
give you their feedback they can leave
comments and vote stars and tell you
which ones no they like the best to
maybe give you some guidance as to which
one should pick once that's done again
you can then pick your winning design
hire the person if there's any final
tweaks they can make it for you and you
have your final design and again the
best thing about it is you're paying for
winning design so you know I didn't
quite know what to expect when I had
this infographic project I had an
article that was top 10 reasons to
partner with someone and I wanted to
turn it into a cartoon figure and you
know people could easily have submitted
their BIOS and previous work but again
didn't really know what I would end up
getting and if I would like it or not
and so through nine Yin and designs
you're only paying for a result which is
a fantastic way for an entrepreneur
to be able to get some security and
knowledge that you're going to be happy
with the end result so encourage you to
go check it out for any kind of graphic
work that you need done there's a lot of
great designers here really talented and
they can help you grow your business so
if you guys liked the video please give
it a thumbs up I'd love to hear your
thoughts and feedback as well if you
want to leave a comment below the video
and stay tuned for the next episode
you